Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! huge news James
Gunn and Kevin Feige just confirmed the title
of guardians of the galaxy to is volume 2
as an awesome mix volume 2 it just of a play
on the irreverent mix tape theme of the first
movies is I may see get the point it's guarding
the galaxy to but it's volume 2 because it's
awesome mix volume 2 the way James Gunn confirmed
the two is kind of funny technically Kevin
Feige he did it last night at a press Q&A
for Ant Man but not a lot of people realize
what happened until this morning so when I saw
James Gunn make the comment is like is this
is a joke is this easy just kidding is that
doesn't sound like a real title but I think
about it in the context of the awesome mix
I think it totally works the be shooting guardians
pretty soon James Gunn it is already offered
up some details about it namely there will
be no hold like you know know Hawken space
anytime soon know nova they'll be a new member
the guardians team and in the movie thematically
will deal with the issue of shady space dad's
but maybe not all of them will be shitty but
I just like the idea of think he that a better
way to say it would be fathers and their children
will be of a big theme in the movie but I
I like the idea of shady space that's good
you Thanos shitty space dad you have star
lord's dad who's going to be a shitty space
dad turns out in the Marvel universe when
you have a kid in space you will be a terrible
father even Odin who is a hero is kind of
a terrible dad most the time the comics pain
him is is a pretty big Dick for everyone still
wondering about Peter Quill's father best
odds right now are that it Starfox there will
be more humanoids in the film but no more
humans from earth so don't expect Captain
Marvel guardians is one of those franchises
that Marvel has that's so different looking
and feeling from the other Marvel movies it
is been so successful that is going to lead
James Gunn and those guys off by themselves
to bill that universe I little bit more before
they crossover so don't expect any in the
avengers to show up on at least until the
third movie avengers infinity war all bets
are off given Feige he James Gunn of all set
yet definitely everybody has to meet at a
certain point that's an game but that is like
a long ways off in the distance or the really
fun things about Marvel's press Q&A's for
movies is that they also talk a lot about
the other movies so we learned a bunch of
things about the rest of phase 3 going to
the lesson start with Spider Man just because
everybody's been talking about Tom Holland
recently they're still trying to figure out
who the villain is going to be for the first
Spider Man movie they're not doing uncle Ben
origin stories so I'm not expecting them to
repeat villains that we've seen recently either
vitamin symbiont feels like a couple steps
away I mean there just like so many classic
films they haven't done yet but give the Vulture
you have Mysterio you know there's
several big villains they could do before
they go back to been I'm venom is that character
that you March out when Spiderman starts to
get really dark himself research looking at
himself and he goes while I've crossed the
line here and we meet Peter Parker for the
first time he's been to be like 15 in Captain
America Civil War them by time he gets that
first Spider Man movie you be 60 so he's not
ready to be super dark yet I at worst he will
be a little bit emo but not like Toby Maguire
levels of emo next up on the list the Mandarin
still in the Marvel universe if you member
the short they did after Iron Man three they
just suggested that the 10 rings and Mandarin
were real people even though Ben Kingsley
was an imposter during Iron Man three so he
still out there somewhere Marvel isn't quite
ready to use them yet Marvel has a bit of
an issue with that character because for most
of his history in the comics he's a bit of
a racist stereotype Marvel really likes to
release films in China and their very particular
about movies billet into the country they
only let 20 American films in per year and
it's like it's a billion-dollar industry so
they feel like there's something racist in
a movie they're not to let it and so when
the Mandarin does eventually show up don't
expect him to look exactly like he does in
the comics and no Robert Downey Jr has
pretty much said that there is no Iron
Man 4 on the books right now next up Captain
America Civil War so Mark Ruffalo made made
this weird comment where he was like well
of Robert Downey Jr says I'm in the movie
I guess I'm in the movie like he didn't know
whether not he was in like where where his
whole during Civil War Kevin Feige he clarified
that comment that that Mark Ruffalo made he
said whole is not a primary part of Civil
War he may not be part at all people are just
taking that to mean that he might actually
have like a really small part in it like a
really small cameo Civil War the movie is
kind like avengers 2.5 in the do just as so
many characters in it when you look at the
massive list of characters that Marvel has
done in movies before most of those are involved
with Civil War in some way it makes sense
because in the comics almost every single
Marvel character was in it if you guys of
ever been to Disney's D 23 this is also like
the year to do that because given Feige he
said they might be bringing some footage from
Civil War do that they been shooting the movie
for a couple months now so the actually do
have enough footage to show off and enough
footage to build trailer don't be surprised
if the first Civil War trailer drops in August
like the first promo I'm expecting them to
attach a really big trailer to Star Wars in
December but to apply release something way
before that moving onto Ant Man Kevin Feige
he said that they might be doing a Sequel
before avengers infinity war is over like
they might put an extra movie on the books
that they were denounced all their phase 3
movies but they might change that lineup just
a little bit depending on the success of Ant
Man and give it does really well Belfast track
a SQL they're already been some spoilers about
the post credit seems there's amid credit
seen and then there's like and after the credit
seen so be sure to stay through the entire
credits whenever you go see it and please
do not post those post credit spoilers Ant
Man itself isn't like a huge springboard for
the other Marvel movies in the way that the
avengers movies always are but there is a
lot of set up for Doctor strange in it to
so pay attention is not quite as literal is
like an actual seen like I'm not expecting
Doctor strange to show up in the movie but
somatically there is some weirdness in Ant
Man that will give you an idea for the weirdness
of Doctor strange as a movie that's he just
went to England to start shooting Doctor strange
so price start hearing more about that movie
throughout the rest of the year and then just
speaking about the TV universe you it was
mostly referring to daredevil but given Feige
he also confirmed that TV characters would
start showing up in the movies eventually
it's long been rumored that the defenders
would show up in avengers infinity war not
that the defenders is still a long ways off
we still have to do Luke Cage Jessica Jones
an iron fist but do not be surprised if the
street level hero team up shows up in the
big blockbuster superhero team up infinity
wars can be like think the biggest Marvel
party they've ever done on screen they're
going to send invites to everybody it'll be
like an RSVP for the end of the universe before
you know Thanos does his finger snap and
wipes out half the universe just thinking that
that I would be totally surprised if the infinity
gauntlet goes down the exact same way it does
in the comics were Thanos is like I'm courting
death I'm going to kill half the universe in
one finger snap that's part of the classic
infinity gauntlet storyline a big part of that
is the hero's figuring out how to bring back
the have to universe the Thanos kills I'm
expecting movie infinity war to be way simpler
than that and I don't know that we will see
the cosmic entity death it just depends on
how trippy they get with Thor Ragnarok in
guardians of the galaxy to though those are
like the only space-based movies we have right
now so he see a bunch of really weird cosmic
stuff in those movies I can I think will give
us a good idea of how weird infinity works
going to get so that's a whole lot news let
me know what you think about the idea of guarding
the galaxy to being called volume 2 and a
lot of you guys are asking about awesome makes
to that James Gunn has already picked the
tracklist he has and announced it yet though
he said that was one of the first things he
did like before he wrote the screenplay he
picked what awesome makes to was going to
be we got a tease for that at the end guardians
one it was the gift that his mother gave him
that he never opened Celesta Marvel stuff
happening this morning that there was another
Marvel video that I was working on solidus
I'll do that next after do my game of thrones
Q&A is just going to be about Marvel movies
set in the past because Kevin Feige he said
that they're probably going to do another
movie like Captain America the first avenger
that takes place entirely in the past my best
theory about that just off the top my head
is that it would be in humans or it would
be like some another new IP that they haven't
done yet they could always do movie for an
existing franchise like like Iron Man or Captain
America or even Thor and said that we way
in the past entirely but I I don't think that
they would do that right away I think of they're
going to do movie set in the past it what
you would be with relatively minor characters
in will be some sort of new IP it would really
be fun to see war of Kings said in like like
the past in the distant past the galaxy which
does kinda make it sound like Star Wars you
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away but
Disney does own both franchises so they can
rip each other off is much as they want so
let me know if Marvel does a movie set in
the past what do you want them to do roomer
it has to entirely take place in the past
so don't forget game of thrones Q&A coming tonight
be sure to subscribe to get that in the meantime
just in case you haven't seen it I did a game
of thrones video yesterday all about the history
of house Tyrell you can click here to learn
all about that and you can click here to learn
all about guardians of the galaxy 2 and what
James Gunn is said about it so far thank you
so much for watching everybody, let's high
five and I'll see guys tonight!